one of the most commonly used tools in
all of statistics is the notion of a
z-score and one way to think about a
z-score is it's just the number of
standard deviations away from the mean
that a certain data point is so let me
write that down number of standard
deviations i'll write it like this
number of standard deviations from
our population mean
for
a particular
particular
data point
now let's make that a little bit
concrete let's say that you're some type
of marine biologist and you've
discovered a new species of winged
turtles and there's a total of seven
winged turtles the entire population of
these winged turtles is seven
and so you go and you're actually able
to measure all the winged turtles so and
you care about their length and you also
want to care about how are those lengths
distributed lengths
of
winged
winged turtles
all right
and let's say and this is all in
centimeters these are very small turtles
so you discover and these are all adults
so there's a two centimeter one there's
another two centimeter one there's a
three centimeter one there's another two
centimeter one there's a five centimeter
one a one centimeter one and a six
centimeter run
so we have seven data points and from
this and you i encourage you at any
point if you want pause this video and
see if you want to calculate what is the
population mean here we're assuming that
this is the population of all the winged
turtles
well the mean in this situation is going
to be equal to you could add up all
these numbers and divide by seven
and you would then get three and then
using these data points and the mean you
can calculate the population standard
deviation and once again as review i
always encourage you to pause this video
and see if you can do it on your own but
i've calculated that ahead of time the
population standard deviation in this
situation is approximately
around to the hundredths place
1.69
so with this information you should be
able to calculate the z-score for each
of these data points pause this video
and see if you can do that
so let me make a new column here so here
i'm going to put r z score
and if you just look at the definition
what you're going to do for each of
these data points let's say each data
point is x
you're going to subtract from that the
mean
and then you're going to divide that by
the standard deviation
the numerator id over here is going to
tell you how far you are above or below
the mean but you want to know how many
standard deviations you are from the
mean so then you'll divide by the
population standard deviation so for
example this first data point right over
here if i want to calculate its z-score
i will take 2
from that i will subtract 3 and then i
will divide by 1.69
i will divide by 1.69
and if you got a calculator out this is
going to be negative 1 divided by 1.69
and if you use a calculator you would
get this is going to be approximately
negative 0.59
and the z-score for this data point is
going to be the same
that is also going to be negative 0.59
one way to interpret this is this is a
little bit more than half a standard
deviation below the mean and we could do
a similar calculation for data points
that are above the mean let's say this
data point right over here what is its
z-score pause this video and see if you
can figure that out
well it's going to be 6
minus our mean
so minus 3 all of that over the standard
deviation all of that over 1.69
and this if you have a calculator and i
calculated it ahead of time this is
going to be approximately 1.77
so more than one but less than 2
standard deviations above the mean
i encourage you to pause this video and
now try to figure out the z-scores for
these other data points
now an obvious question that some of you
might be asking is why
why do we care how many standard
deviations above or below the mean a
data point is in your future statistical
life
z-scores are going to be a really useful
way to think about how usual or how
unusual a certain data point is and
that's going to be really valuable once
we start making inferences based on our
data so i will leave you there just keep
in mind it's a very useful idea but at
the heart of it a fairly simple one if
you know the mean you know the standard
deviation
take your data point subtract the mean
from the data point and then divide by
your standard deviation that gives you
your z-score